in the last 20 years i've dealt with
many realtors both on a residential
commercial side
whether it's buying buildings leasing
office space or whether it's buying
homes or renting vacation properties
and i've experienced working with great
ones good ones
and some bad ones and today i'm going to
give you a perspective of your
relationship with your realtor
that maybe no one's explained to you
before and if it makes any sense you get
value from it
i want you to give you a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and share it
with others as well so look when it
comes down to buying or selling a house
there's four parties involved typically
there's four parties involved there's
you
there's your realtor there's them there
is their realtor right
and you could be the buyer they're the
seller you could be the seller they're
the buyer but regardless there's
typically four parties involved right
now the question you have to ask
yourself is how many different
teams are there teams how many teams are
there what do you mean by that pat
here's what i mean by it i mean you and
your realtor
you are one team right them
and their realtor is one team but
there's one other team
that no one thinks about that 90 of the
time
have a longer relationship together than
the rest of them do and here's who it is
is your realtor and their realtor let me
explain to what i mean by this
how many times are you going to do
business with your realtor
how many times is the seller going to do
business with their realtor
versus how many times are your realtor
and their realtor going to do business
together let's just say you do business
together with them once
maybe twice maybe three times maybe they
do twice three times maybe four times
how often do you think they're going to
do business together five times
10 times 20 30 40 time what if they're
the main guys
in the city that you're buying a house
or buying a building or selling a
property think about it
and they've both been around for 20
years you don't think they know of each
other you don't think they've done
business together
you don't think they know that on the
next deal coming up they're going to
have to so
if they push too hard on the next one
you get where i'm going with this right
so here's how it goes you go to your
realtor and you say oh my gosh i love
this building this is the building we
want to buy this the office we want to
buy
we love this office we love this
building this is the building
this one everybody on the team loves it
and you tell your realtor thinking
this realtor's on your team right okay
then
the other side the seller says
look i just won't let you know i'm not
selling this thing for less than
you know i have to get my seven million
dollars even though it's on the market
for eight and a half million
now his realtor knows seven million is
to cut off now
then they talk so your realtor's like
okay let me see what i
want to go get the best deal for you
their realtor goes okay let me let me
get i want to get them more than 7
million
i'm going to do my best but it's good to
know where you're at and then the two
realtors
unite and they talk so what does it look
like well i tell you you know he's not
he's he's got a number and he's not one
what number do you think you can get him
for i don't know i i think it's gonna be
stretch at seven million i think i think
your your buyers got to go with seven
seven
they're not gonna go there these guys
gonna go at six nine well i don't know
what we can do
look see if you can get them at this
number here let me go back and talk to
them
and they go back to talk they both want
to sell it at the highest possible value
including your realtor
especially if you're the buyer they make
more money if you sell it for 7 million
instead of 6.5 million that's an
additional five hundred thousand dollars
a commission
you think it's fully them wanting to get
it for you not all the time
so then they come back and they say okay
why don't we do this
uh i think i can get them for seven yeah
i i got them they like the house a lot
they like the building garage you can
tell from the motion i saw the wife the
wife was
very excited they really want the house
they want this place to
okay great no problem then let's try to
sell it for 7.2 million
and then they go back and forth so
because they have the relationship
this is the part where buyers and
sellers forget
that no matter how much you do business
with your realtor the two realtors are
bigger team than you know in the most
indirect way
attorneys two divorce attorneys when
they talk to each other
what do you think both divorce attorneys
know drag this thing out
the longer it goes the more hours we can
charge
you know the code wink wink let's keep
going
similar model now some realtors are
watching this they're pissed off at me
how dare you make a video like this and
talk about this in this manner
i'm not talking about this in this
manner i'm just telling you
most realtors are like this now let me
give you some of the realtors
that work as partners i dealt with one
i'll dealt with a couple of them jackie
dorbert's being one of them in dallas
she showed me properties for four years
and i never bought anything from her
patient incredibly patient constantly
calling me back to
everything was so respectful for four
years this woman never made any money
off of me
but she eventually got a nice hundred
thousand dollar check plus
from us not on a couple hundred thousand
dollar check from us
for what she did because she was a great
realtor she did her part
right and there's many others here so
now if you're watching and say well pat
what can i do to make sure that as the
buyer or the seller
the realtor is fully on my side uh-huh
you're asking the right question now
here's what it is either find a realtor
that you're going to do repetitive
business together for for many many
years to come
or become the following i tell all the
people i do business with here's what i
tell them i say listen
i'm probably going to be your greatest
referral source of your career
what do you mean i'm probably going to
send you more referrals than
anyone's ever sent you in your entire
life
so guess what you better take care of me
because if you don't those
referrals are going somewhere else and
i'm telling it as a joke but i'm not
joking i'm dead serious
so if you're watching the same how can i
get to that point influence be somebody
that gives a referrals out to people if
you say you're going to give referrals
out to people do it
if your realtor is so good tell the
world about it
if your realtor's done such an
outstanding job for you
protect them tell the world give the
referral call your family call your
friends
work for them because when it comes down
to it they will 100 be on your side
because they know you are the
relationship
they don't want to lose not the other
relationship their concern becomes you
not the relationship with the realtor
you because you give them referrals
and you don't do one deals you do two
three because you're a be back customer
and be back customers are very very hard
to find so having said that
if you watch this video and you got
value out of it put a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and share with
your friends
and your peers and if your realtor
watching this and you disagree i would
love to hear your thoughts by the way
i did another video four or five years
ago negotiating an office lease if
you're about to lease an office space
and you want to know the dynamics i will
lease in my career through my company
probably a million and a half square
feet of office space
a lot and i've dealt with many of them
it's probably not a bad idea for you to
watch this video when it comes out to at
least an office space as well
take care everybody bye-bye bye bye